It's not a partner car administration, but it's just one of the possibilities Oh,
if there's a member who would like to have a good opportunity to have a good discussion with your partner and try it
out, please
let me know We don't need to shuffle, right?
Terunda Karane 9 Koro-chan
[Music]
Could it be zero ii I'm worried about something I went there before I want you to talk about having a 0 zoom and I want to know more about zero ii
I guess that's right
[  Music]
So, if you're worried about something right now, talk to me It
's annoying.
It takes courage to say that if you want
to, so
face people and face yourself.
What did you want me to recognize
?
It's much better
hoax,
I'm different from
you Then, if you're a member who wants to try other partners
, please let me test the connection between them.
I want
15 You won't cooperate I'm sorry I don't
mindbut
let's do it
Let me try 3 other things
I promised Kokoro-chan